again one of those
profound looking over the ocean maybe
sitting on a porch
maybe with a drink of some kind um
and a young kid comes by and asks you
for advice what advice would you give to
drink that's my advice
i'm serious so
okay after that
uh what advice would you give to a young
person today as they take on life
whether career in academia in general or
just
a life which is probably more important
than career
most good advice is context specific but
here are my two generic pieces of advice
good first get a mentor both
career but anything you want to learn
like say you want to learn about
contemporary art
people write me this uh what book should
i read it's
probably not going to work that way you
need a mentor yes you should read some
books on it
but you want a mentor to help you frame
them take you around to some art
talk about it with you so get as many
mentors as you can
in the things you want to learn and then
ask you a quick
yeah uh a tangent on that uh
presumably a good mentor of course is
there
begging the question in there it's
complicated right
well it is complicated is there a lot of
damage to be done from a bad mentor
i don't think that much because it's
very easy to drop mentors and in fact
it's quite hard to maintain them
good mentors tend to be busy ad mentors
tend to be busy
yeah uh and you can try on mentors and
maybe they're not good for you but you
still
there's a good chance you'll learn
something
like i had a mentor i was an undergrad
he was a stalinist
he edited the book called the essential
stalin brilliant guy
i learned a tremendous amount from him
was he like as a stalinist a good mentor
for me fan of fayak well no
but for a year it was tremendous
hmm yeah he introduced me like to you
know soviet and eastern european science
fiction because he was a marxist
like that's what i took from him among
other things any advice on finding a
good mentor
daniel kahneman has
somebody just popped this to mind as
somebody who was able to find
exceptionally good collaborators
throughout his life there's not many
bright minds that find collaborators
they often
um which i ultimately see what a mentor
is
yeah interesting be direct and try
it's not like a perfect formula but it's
amazing how many people don't even do
those things
be interesting be direct and try
like what you want from a better known
person i would just say be very direct
with them
yeah beautiful what's the second piece
of advice
build small groups of peers they don't
have to be your age
but very often they'll be your age
especially if you're younger
with broadly similar interests but there
can be different points of view
people you hang out with which could
include in a whatsapp group online
and like every day or almost every day
they're talking about
the thing you care about trying to solve
problems in that thing
and that's your small group and you
really like them and they like you and
you care what you think about each other
and you have this common interest that's
for human connection or that's for
development of ideas
it's both they're not that different
like beatles classic small group right
uh but there's so much drama the
florentine artists of course there's
drama and small groups tend to split up
which is fine
just like entering relationships off an
end
but it's remarkable how little has been
done that was not done in small groups
in some way
you